♪～
こんにちは　はじめしゃちょーです。
実家です。
いつもどおり……
なにか
紹介しようと思ったんですけど、こう…
実家にいると何か…集中…できないんですよ。
(振り返る）
別に普通に、うぇーいってできるんんですけど…
(小声）なんか
違うんですよ。
なんか親が、マミーがいると
なんか
いつもの力が発揮できないんで、
ネタがない訳じゃないんですけど…
ネタができないんで、
質問コーナーです。
(拍手)×２
見てきましょう。
おお＾＾
……
土田ですぎｗｗｗｗ
ガンダムのやつですよね。
土田さんも多分…
土田さんも出たくないです。広告に
土田さんも
ガンダムの広告の人に出ろって言われて出てるんで、
土田さんを責めないでくださいm(－－)m
SONY NEX 5R使っていますか？
はい
SONY NEX 5Rこれです。今、これ、が、その、SONYの
……
SIREN早く見たいです！！　お願いします(－－)
SIRENしたいんですけど
……………
実家なんで(小声)ちょっと…
オープニングもうちょっとだけ時間伸ばしてほしい
♫♪～
画質が変
(ロボット声)画質変ですか？
はじめしゃちょーなで肩！！！
僕なで肩じゃじゃ
なで肩じゃないですよ～
…
で？くだらん
（うるうる）
マミー↑(泣）
はじめ社長‼あの〇✕△＠％
オフ会ですかー…
開きたいんですけど…
スー(息を吸う)
ん、どうだろ、まだ未定ですね。
あのアバンティーズと、
６面ステーションとマーキュリーマーキュリーオフ会にはちょっと…
行こうかな
微妙です。
ドラム叩いて！
ジャーン
ドラムやってください
ドドドン　ジャーン
彼女いんの？
マミー↑(泣）
お腹減った(^^)/
バリッ　バリッ　バリッ　バリッ
私も食べる！
家の隣に、野良猫にえさを与えて、いい人ぶる根性の悪い
バリッ　バリッ　バリッ　バリッ
わしの家の隣に住んでいる根性の悪い二枚舌の糞ババアは、
わしは、猫が大っ嫌いだ‼野良猫
バリッ　バリッ　バリッ　バリッ
個人的にエンディングのBGMが頭から@〇△✕▢＠%
🎶
（口笛）♫🎵～